hey guys I want to share with you the
absolute best stretch for sciatica pain
sonica pain is where you have pain that
goes down the back the leg on one side
or even both and it's really a disc
protrusion and what I notice with cases
with Vatika is that the curve in their
lower back they lost the curve it's
straight up and down that puts a
tremendous amount of stress on the last
two discs okay and what happens when you
lose your curve you lose that spring and
you start getting a disc bulge that goes
into the back of the spinal column
either on the right or left side and the
pain goes right down the leg especially
if you're driving your car in one
position you can really irritate that
nerve okay so the stretch that I'm going
to show you literally puts the curve
back into your lower back so you have
this cushion it opens up the disc it is
the best thing for sciatica and you're
just going to need one of these it's a
foam roller get in that target get an X
wherever online that's how you're going
to need so now limiters I'm just going
to demonstrate how to do it's really
simple okay so this is what you do you
take this little thing right here and
you're going to place it right on your
lower back but you're not going to put
it down here you're going to put it at
l1 right there and you're going to lay
lean back right here on the floor with
your knees up and it's pushing the curve
up it's going to start forming the curve
you're going to lay here for about two
or three or four or five minutes and
you're going to put your knees up and
you're just going to let the ground the
foam roller push that curve up remember
don't put it like too low raise it
higher we're about the first lumbar
vertebra so we can actually really put
that curve back it's going to take all
the pressure off the nerve and your side
is going to go away so I would do this
in the morning and at night five minutes
you can't go wrong so go ahead and try
it out put your comments below